- Let's give ourselves a
little bit more practice
adding and subtracting
positive and negative numbers.
So, let's say that we have the statement,
four is equal to negative eight
minus blank.
Like always, I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can figure
out what blank would be
to make the statement true.
That negative eight minus blank
is going to be equivalent to four.
That four is equal to
negative eight minus blank.
So now, let's work it through together.
To help us I will get a number line.
So there's a number line right over there.
And, one way to think about it is,
I wanna start at negative eight,
so this is negative five, negative six,
negative seven, negative eight.
I wanna start at negative eight
and I wanna do something to negative eight
to end up at four.
To end up at four.
So four is positive one, two, three, four.
So that's four right over there.
So, what do I need to do
to get from negative eight
to positive four?
Well let's see.
I have to move to the
right one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11, 12.
I have to the right 12 spaces.
Or another way to think about it,
to get from negative
eight to positive four
I have to, I'm just gonna make sure
I have some space up here,
I have to add 12.
Another way to think about it,
to get from negative eight to zero,
you have to add eight.
Then to get from zero to four,
you have to add another four.
So you have to add eight plus four, or 12.
But how do you do that?
'Cause they're saying
negative eight minus something
should be equal to four.
Whatever you have over here,
you want this to end up
the equivalent to plus 12,
so what can you do there?
Well you could subtract a negative.
If you subtracted negative 12,
this would be equivalent to adding 12.
So notice, let me rewrite it,
four is equal to,
let me just write it
without my boxes there,
is equal to negative
eight minus negative 12.
Well what happens when
you subtract a negative?
Well that ends up being
adding the positive.
So this is gonna be the same thing as
negative eight plus positive 12,
or four is equal to negative 8 plus 12,
which we know is true.
You add eight you get to zero,
negative eight plus eight is zero,
then you add another four,
you get to positive four.
So that one was pretty interesting.
Let's do another one, we
can't get enough practice,
this is too much fun.
All right.
So let's say we had...
let's say we had
something blank
minus negative two
is equal to negative seven.
How do we think about this?
Well the first thing my brain wants to do
is to simplify subtracting a negative.
So if you subtract negative two
that's the same thing
as adding positive two.
So this is an equivalent statement to say,
something subtracting a negative two
is the same thing as
adding a positive two.
Something plus two is
equal to negative seven.
And now we can get the number
line out to think about it.
So, get my number line out.
So, my goal, my goal is
I wanna get to negative seven.
So there's negative five, negative six,
negative seven right there.
And I wanna add two to something
to get to negative seven.
So if I'm adding two that
means I'm jumping two,
I'm jumping two to the right,
that's what adding two looks like.
So what number do I need to start at
that if I jump two to
the right, if I add two
I end up at negative seven?
Well I would have to start two to the left
of negative seven.
If I start two to the left, one, two,
if I started...
Let me do this in a different color.
If I start at this number right here
and if I add two, plus one, plus two,
I end up at negative seven.
Well what number is this?
This number that is two to
the left of negative seven.
Well it's negative nine.
So this right over here is negative nine.
Negative nine plus two,
so if you start at negative nine
and you move two to the right
you end up at negative seven.
Or, you could say, negative nine
minus negative two, 'cause
if you subtract negative two
you're going to move to the right.
If you subtract positive
two, you move to the left.
But then if you subtract negative two,
you move two to the
right, to negative seven.
Another fascinating one.
Let's do one more of these,
I'm having maybe a
little bit too much fun.
All right.
So let's say we have negative four
is equal to blank minus nine.
So let's get the number line out
and always pause the video, see if you can
try it on your own.
But let's get my number line out
and so let's think about it.
Our goal, we wanna take some number
subtract nine from it
and get negative four.
So we wanna get negative four
and then there's some number
that if we take nine away from it.
So if you take nine away from something
that's moving nine to the left.
So, another way to think
about subtracting nine,
let me do this in a different color,
subtracting nine.
That's literally moving nine to the left.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
So there's some number that we start with,
we're gonna subtract nine
and then we end up with negative four.
We're gonna end up with negative four.
Some number, that's the
blank right over here,
you subtract nine, you
move nine to the left,
that's gonna be equal to negative four.
So another way to think about it is,
this number is gonna be nine
to the right of negative four.
So let's think about what
that number's gonna be.
So this number is gonna be nine
to the right of negative four.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
It looks like positive five.
So let's see if we're right about that.
If we start as positive
five and we subtract nine,
so let's do that, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Yup, you subtract nine,
you're gonna end up at negative four.
So negative four is
equal to five minus nine.